nowadays competitive Shooters are
becoming more and more geared towards a
younger audience Apex is for Zoomers who
dry scoop G fuel
oh my God fortnite is for literal
fetuses
and even now in 2022 we have an actual
teenagers competing in and in some cases
winning CS go majors Jax surely can drop
it oh but he's been fumbling with his
knees and they both line up for him two
more headshots for the tally and bit
puts G2 down in the dump as things get
more elaborate and fast-paced the
players who are a bit older can find
themselves out of their element in a
genre they practically birthed
but there are still Old-Timers out there
who enjoy a challenge those who aren't
deterred by the skill of the middle
schoolers who are coming for their Crown
but inspired by it meet Perry 2N the
Cali raised breakdancing Boomer who has
recently been Making Waves as a valorent
content creator not for nutty flicks or
outrageous one Taps but mathematical
lineups and methodical mind games that
he uses to turn his weaknesses into
strengths
oh my God
oh my God Perry let's go Perry let's go
so how did your run of the Mills CS go
Boomer turn into a radiant stim daddy
main what pushed Perry to throw himself
into the world of memes and content
creation and most importantly how have
his Infamous mollies become every
player's worst nightmare
don't tell me I'm playing against
Perry dude
all right so before we get into the
video I wanted to let you all know that
we got new merch if you can't touch
grass IRL you can do the next best thing
and get a hoodie that reminds all your
friends to do it for you and even if
grass isn't your thing head over to
shop.thescore.com and check out all of
the designs because we got a few and
they're all cool all right so before our
30 year old cat lover was melting Minds
with his murderous Molly methods he was
busting moves across SoCal under the
Alias Perry too nice that's right on top
of being a capital G gamer Perry had an
actual hobby that took him outside to
touch actual grass
all right well the waxed floors of a
high school gym
[Music]
[Applause]
but outside of his b-boy escapades and
inside CS go servers Perry dropped the
ice from his name and injected it
straight into his veins as a no-nonsense
offer my hair steps
nice top head down
uh the 28 a wrap
he's downstairs he's downstairs
oh snap I'm warm now despite hitting
Global Elite during his younger days
Perry Never managed to break into the
pro scene so after years of trying and
failing to make it in Counter-Strike
Perry swapped over to OverWatch as a
grand master Reaper Mane Perry combined
the creativity of his break dancing days
and the wisdom of his steadily advancing
years to shoot people in the face but as
skillful as he was in both CS go and
OverWatch
something was missing for Perry when
valorent first came out Perry thought
he'd finally found a game that spoke to
his talents the thing is at first his
age had actually caught up with him
first character I think I got my hands
on was actually Phoenix and again it was
same thing with like the Duelist role
like I found early on that I just
couldn't really go toe-to-toe uh with
because I'm not in my Prime anymore and
my rifling's kind of like it's like
passable but it's not like
um it's not like cracked as as people
say these days Perry eventually bounced
off of Duelists since well in addition
to being way too based for that he
was
too old so being a boomer of above
average intelligence Perry ironically
took it upon himself to start mastering
valorence ostensibly senile smoke
deploying strategist Brimstone they
think I'm an old dog
I'll show him just how many tricks I
know and Perry quickly noticed something
about brim's incendiary ability that
others seemingly didn't it didn't
disintegrate you see in CS go Molly's
can't be thrown over long distances if
they're in the air for more than two
seconds they explode into nothing
inflicting zero damage this means that
lineups can only be used in close to
medium proximity from the area one
intends to hit brim on the other hand
can launch his Molly from anywhere the
issue is that useful as he was brim was
sort of seen as a boring agent players
understood his practicality but the
consensus was that he just wasn't as fun
or flashy as an omen or a jet but to
Perry brim wasn't just useful
he was broken I think I found Molly
lineups really early on in beta it was
like a pretty interesting mechanic and
the Molly's last like super long do a
crap ton of damage right like I don't
think you can even tank half the the
Molly if it's already landed on the bomb
I'm on the older side I'm like a boomer
playing Brimstone so like uh you know I
don't have like the crazy Zoomer
mechanics anymore so that like it's just
another way to win and I don't think
people a lot of people recognize that
after that Eureka moment Perry took to
custom servers put on his lab coat and
started experimenting like the ancient
nerd that he was he planted the bomb in
various default positions and began
innovating increasingly intricate
lineups around the map eventually Perry
could land a Molly on the bomb from just
about anywhere and once in the server
that eight second Molly combined with
brim's alt made diffusing it damn near
impossible
reloading
oh yeah
oh get it no I tried man dude that thing
takes so long Harry didn't let his
successes get to his head though he knew
that his mechanics weren't what they
used to be and that trying to keep up
with all these Twitchy and Jet abusers
was an uphill battle so he played to his
strengths once the bomb was down Perry
got the hell out of Dodge and Let the
Flames do all the work this stroke of
Genius helped Perry climb the ranks all
the way to radiant and as any Valor
player knows once you start making your
way into radiant lobbies you're playing
with some of the biggest names in not
only the competitive world but the
streaming one and although most people
didn't really know Perry's name at first
let me tell you
they learned it pretty fast you
know when my team is getting absolutely
railed by Perry it's a it's a team that
this had a molly
lemonade
nice nice I'm getting on it I'm getting
on it I'll stick all right
don't tell me I'm playing against
Perry dude
has every single lineup I've ever seen
here approached valorin with sort of a
novel mindset he won rounds without
fragging with brim's alt and Perry's
many Molly post plant options he could
clutch Outpost plans without firing a
single bullet end
for some people that was very very
aggravating
now
oh my God
imagine putting in all the the hard work
it takes to retake a site only to see
your efforts thwarted by a flaming
tennis ball but to his credit Perry
wasn't just winning rounds with mollies
and alts alone at the end of the day
valorent is about shooting and even
though Perry couldn't quite click heads
with the best of them he created his own
unique approach
too long one open up the sky
I don't know okay bro
okay Perry had plenty of experience with
shotguns from his days as a Reaper Mane
in fact the reticle on the judge is
nearly identical to Reapers akimbo
sawed-off thingies which really helped
if Perry was past his days of TAPS and
sprays he could pick up the shoddy and
just send it instead and trust me when I
say that a Caked Up Brimstone with a
12 gauge is the last thing that
anyone expects oh brim plays U-Haul with
a judge everywhere
that being said every once in a while
Perry still goes back to his CS roots
and throws down with an OP
taken down
you're different now let's make
something very clear Perry using
shotguns and ops isn't just another way
for him to crutch himself out of a fair
fight
it's actually quite the opposite there's
a good reason people don't expect a brim
with a shoddy or sniper rifle it's a bad
idea brim doesn't have a dash or any
kind of get out of jail free card the
way that agents who usually opt and use
shotguns do so if a brim plays
aggressively they can quickly find
themselves twisting in the wind but
Perry is a grown man with a mature
sophisticated logic and his answer to
that conundrum was simple
don't miss most of the time when I pull
that out uh everyone starts to freak out
they're like oh why are you doing that
you should you like you should be doing
that on jet or we already have enough
it's on jet
Brimstone is popping
that's what we were doing when we first
got back to the game Chad people were
like you're dropping on Brimstone but
then like I came from CS go so like it
was pretty common to play like uh on CT
side with two Ops for instance on like a
specific map like Mirage so
um that's why I was super comfortable
with it even though I don't have like a
like an escape mechanic on Brimstone
because he's like really slow he has no
dash or whatever but uh yeah pretty
confident in that first shot 10 seconds
left
out of charges Spike down a one enemy
remaining
[Applause]
but for all of Perry's triumphs
still has his haters see as inspiring as
Perry's quest to the top ranks of
valorent may seem he is kind of the
antithesis to all of valorence Unwritten
rules he plays aggressively as a
controller uses weapons he shouldn't and
worst of all he's a lineup Larry does it
have a money lineup
look at this nerd look at this nerd oh
my God
off some brim you got that Molly line up
shorty Molly lineups on for him at its
core memes be damned valorent is about
shooting people in the face so a lot of
these brain dead reignon chamber Mains
get a sour taste in their mouth when
they lose out on a round because some
nerd used his Noggin to launch a
fireball across the map but Perry
couldn't care less if the kitties out
there find him cringe or boring in fact
it's quite the opposite as a content
creator Perry has a leaned into the meme
and even Revels in the idea that his
brim lives rent free in zoomer's Minds
everywhere hey guys welcome back to my
channel for those of you that are new
here my name is Perry twin and I'm one
of the first Brimstone Mains to hit
radiant using Molly lineups judge op and
shorty what's more Perry is just so damn
good at what he does that even the
saltiest most valorant accent shaders
out there can't help but admire him
almond TP like long or something
you are the best in this video game bro
dude I've seen that so many times it's
amazing it's so fun to watch and as
frustrating as it may be to be on the
receiving end of it all it's hard to
shame a guy for outsmarting his
opponents and pioneering a strategic
playstyle that plays to his strengths in
Counter-Strike players are revered for
coming up with sick meta-altering
lineups why should it be any different
in valorant on top of that it's not as
if what Perry's doing is somehow unfair
or overpowered he's just taking an
underappreciated ability and maximizing
its potential both of Molly loves are so
insane they're so underrated I feel like
any time we run a brimstone we would try
to get into a postman situation where
the brimstone Molly because nine times
out of ten you're winning that because
Brimstone boys are insane I've always
been a strong advocate a brimstone my
lineups I think they're insane and you
know hats off to anyone who's actually
spent the time to really learn some cool
brim somalian-ups pair
Creator from break dancing to memeing to
mollies he simply uses his imagination
to excel at the things he loves
oh my God
oh my God Perry let's go Perry let's go
you see Perry isn't some dinosaur
styling on kids half his age by doing
geometry homework on the server I mean
he is doing that he's just not that old
and on a serious note we can learn a lot
from Harry he proves that you don't need
to be an aim God to win rounds you can
be past your Prime and still succeed
because there is no definitive right way
to outsmart one's opponents regardless
of your limitations real or imaginary
there's always a way to get where you
want to go sometimes all it takes is a
bit of patience commitment
and creativity so don't hate the Perry
hate the game
yeah he got it
concentrate holy you want it
that's Epic
I love that I can I can only respect it
like imagine being a Reaper mate like
what the do you even do with that I
know there was a time when he was like a
lot better but like oh they picked
pharah
I'm not even Throwing Shade I just like
I I respect it the man hit GM playing a
Reaper
unbelievable genuinely unbelievable how
how
crazy